[Musique]
tout au long de l'histoire, il y a eu des
guerriers appelés Chevaliers, le gagnant
remportera le symbole de la chevalerie cette
armure Pegasus hommes et femmes avec des pouvoirs
comme vous n'en avez jamais vu
aujourd'hui une nouvelle génération de Chevaliers
contrôle le destin du monde
John King ils  sont appelés les chevaliers
du zodiaque ensemble, nous pouvons faire tout ce que
nous sommes attaqués,
laissez-les simplement mettre la main sur l'
or sur terre, vous avez ma parole, c'est
plus que BC et les chevaliers doivent être capables
de faire les choses que personne ne peut faire  était
génial allez encore
ce sont la nuit noire quelque chose de diabolique
nous devons attaquer ensemble dis et maintenant
Pegasus
stea
brûle ton Cosmo
toi